One of the best films that I saw in 2014
was two grand Budapest hotel,
written and directed by West Anderson
was Edison is of course known for
distinctive style in particular his
fullness for perfectly symmetrical
shots,
which she spoke loft and hated for as
less than some screenplays states.
Some people consider west Anderson a
genius death converse conventional film
language into its own dialectic while
others claim it is artfulness mistake
and for art film devoid of meaning.
I think these opposing opinions own wes
Anderson style stem from a fundamental
paradox in how people look at movies and
even broader nature.
Perfect symmetry is a natural and
conventional cinematic language is
designed to have the audience not notice
consciously,
at least the manufactured nature or what
happens on screen.
West Anderson therefore draws attention
away from the story and characters on
screen and to watch his cinematic style.
Yet,
although symmetry is a natural,
people do find it beautiful.
It's movies therefore function more as a
painting or storybook than conventional
narrative cinema.
I was argued this,
that it is critical for us and listen to
match this narrative characters and
dialogue with a cinematic style so that
is fewer accepted as fitting instead of
all natural,
and I think he does this perfectly and
the Grand Budapest hotel where a
moonrise kingdom and as soon alludes to
a cinematic stele mimicking the metrical
storybooks,
susie bishop carries twitter in the
Grand Budapest hotel.
He creates a frame story,
a story within a story,
within a story,
within a story.
He even matches the aspect ratio of the
narratives,
different time periods to the aspect
ratio that was confessional for cinema
in the years.
The story finance itself to this frame
story,
the Grand Budapest hotel is submersed in
Ostalgie throwing us back into a more
elegant time or aristocracy is civility
and taste.
This nostalgia is towards the magical
world of the past,
or even as his hinted or Walter Earth is
even older.
To be frank,
I think his world had vanished long
before he ever rented it,
but I will say he certainly sustained
the illusion with a marvelous grace.
I would say that this nostalgic,
elegant world matches perfectly with
innocence painting slash storybook,
like cinematic style.
Even the 40 aspect ratio of the 19
thirties that he uses for the part of
the story that is set in that time
period works excellent for symmetric
shots.
This is all even further complemented by
the dialogue.
Once you Gustaf especially converses in
an elegant aristocratic way which is in
tune.
The magical world that is created
rudeness is merely the expression of
fear.
People fear they won't get what they
want.
The most dreadful and unattractive
person earlier needs to be loved and
they will open up like a flower.
I'm reminded of a verse.
The painter's brush touch the incubate
phase,
ends of Nimble bristles and color.
Granted,
her life is cheap.
The danger of this or wherever it is
that this dialogue cool to receive the
same critique as wes Anderson cinematic
style often does that it is pretentious
and listen solstice by frequently having
mature Gustaf breaking as elegant.
Speaking with a more professional tone.
I've never seen her like that before.
No,
sir.
She was shaking like a shitting dog.
Truly,
this creates comedic moments and serves
as a wink to the audience.
It shows an awareness of the
criticalness style
you see that are still glimmers of
civilization left and this barbaric
slaughter house that was once known as
humanity.
Indeed,
that's what we provide in our own
modest,
humble,
insignificant.
Okay.
Another problem is that by drawing
attention to a cinematic style,
wes Anderson,
districts and distances to audience from
the emotional lives of the characters on
screen.
Most of innocence films are a mixture of
tragedy and comedy is cinematic style
works perfectly for comedic purposes.
For example,
I think people entered a frame in many
ways,
just like Edgar Wright sometimes does
birth more central to establish our.
His tracking shots is tableau shots.
He's a ruthless adventure of a con
artist who preys on mentally sick.
Old Ladies probably box them to bed with
all my friends.
This tableau shot of mature Gustaf in
Jill created an absurdity death folks
after birth.
It also distracts from the seriousness
of his situation because when it comes
to more serious emotional moments,
it is precisely this kind of shot that
can distance the audience from the
characters.
In previous movies,
Edison therefore returned to cinematic
techniques outside of his own style.
During these moments,
for example,
he returns to the more conventional over
the shoulder shots in moonrise kingdom.
When Sam and Susie confessed the love
for each other as bought all states at
an emotional peak,
innocence sharply violates the film's
intrinsic norm by bringing in their
common technique.
West Emerson doesn't do this in the
Grand Budapest hotel,
however,
birth uses lighting color and some
techniques that fit within this
intrinsic style to convey important
emotional moments.
The audience in this tableau shots,
a lighting change signifies that a more
serious moment is about to happen,
and another line inq combined with a
closeup focuses on the tears.
Old Zero.
You see,
I never speak to him,
I guess because even the thought of her
name,
I'm unable to control my emotions.
Well,
I suppose there's no way around it.
In a similar way,
a shelter is to convey Agatha so love of
serious life center usher in a close up
with soft lighting and light circling
binder.
Wes Anderson also use objects and
positioning to convey emotional cues
when we see more sugary stuff in his
solitary small room where he eats dinner
alone,
which is a break with the royal elegant
self-assured,
Short speaking persona of material
stuff.
The camera lights over a couple of
bottles layer,
the peneche his favorite perfume.
Perfume is this part of his more
intimate and it's rather lonely
personality when he shares this perfume
with zero does signify serious access to
star spiritual world and their deep
friendship.
I owe you my life.
You are my dear friend and process.
Every private,
if you.
You must admit.
I'm so sorry he's here.
We're brothers.
We can also see this in their positions
in the frame,
in the beginning of the film,
zero is often seen in the background.
While most sugar stuff,
the more dominating character at that
point is shown larger and closer to the
front of the frame.
The same compositional structure can be
seen with the antagonist of the film
birth with regards to Ciro and more good
stuff.
Later in the film,
their friendship develops and they
become more equals zero rescue of
material,
good stuff from jail.
We see this shift within the mission
seven s,
they both now shared frame more equally
yet it's the most clear example where
wes Anderson cues and important
emotional moments too.
Cinematic style is in the train scene
near the end.
This scene is similar to an earlier
train scene,
yet completely different where the first
train scene is shown in warm colors and
there was room for comedic moments.
It's not a very flattering portrait.
I'm afraid I was once considered a great
but
wants the f stand for Fritz France,
France.
I knew it.
West End Shin shows the later train
scene in black and white to convey what
would be one of the saddest days of life
when will show stuff is shoved debt.
What happened in the end and the and
they shot him.
The grants Budapest hotel signifies,
I think the peak of West innocence
ability folk,
both comedy as emotional strategy to his
own distinctive cinematic style.
The film is a wonderful mix of charm,
humor,
and sadness accumulation off west
innocence work as a director and writer
that will make you want to revisit the
Grand Budapest hotel again and again and
again and again,
thank you so much for watching.
And every time I see this film I
appreciated more and more and it is
slowly turning into one of my favorite
films ever.
If you want to help us out and get
access to extra content,
you can support us on Patrion.
Uh,
all help is welcome.
Of course.
Follow us on facebook and twitter and we
will see you next week with a video from
Thomas.